yesterday the GOP did something that
made people really mad did you see this
they tweeted out a mug shot of
presidential hopeful Beto O'Rourke that
some people say defames the Irish this
is an old mugshot of better O'Rourke he
did that they put that out there yeah
thank you say that again don't be quick
on the trigger there bill there they put
that out on st. Patrick's Day he's
ruined now I know once you put an Irish
hat on someone they're throwing it
through them as well anyway as an Irish
American I just want to remind the
Republicans that we the Irish are more
than capable of denigrating ourselves
okay we don't need help in fact here's a
little reminder that we can do it all on
our own
take a look she wants me go today where
you won't be getting my vote is and you
won't be getting like
I don't think there is another piece of
tape that more accurately just like
describes what being around you in real
life right there everyday everyday be
College Admission scandal still going on
a yeah a prominent psychiatrist said
that Felicity Huffman Lori Loughlin and
many other celebrities suffer from
something called acquired situational
narcissism yeah yeah I start reading the
article because it wasn't about me
I don't know why I do that that's the
worst thing to do after you get a lap on
a joke and I'm I'm an hey people
are really upset with JK Rowling I know
if you heard about this they're upset
with JK Rowling for saying that there
was a gay relationship between
Dumbledore and Grindelwald I'm with you
yeah I think it's sad that in 2019
people are offended by what's going on
between two consenting Wizards they want
to cross wands that's their business
[Applause]
I yesterday was st. Patrick's Day we had
kind of an unfortunate
well coincidence here at our show let me
tell you what happened once a year we
have a mandatory drug test for all of
our employees that is standard it
happens every year this year the drug
test was scheduled for today the day
after st. Patrick's Day yeah it was kind
of it made for an uncomfortable scene
check it out
specimen please have a good st.
Patrick's Day yeah animals next
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]